I'm very happy to have Steve crashing
here I mentioned on my YouTube channel
that you were gonna be here and a number
of my viewers said oh please let us know
what you find out and what you learn is
over it so better than that we're gonna
do a discussion and you were going to
explain something exciting that's
happening or ideas a new number of
things are on my mind I still still
finding things out still learning stuff
right it's amazing and it's accelerating
not decelerating good the turning point
was retiring
okay years ago right yes well you got
busier you got your sponsors yeah oh my
goodness yes in the area what I did here
at the conference a little bit new this
is my first encounter with all these
wonderful hyperpolyglots people who know
all the languages in my talk I talked
about whether my work is consistent with
their experiences and the major part was
to say we're gonna look at case
histories and if I find one case history
of any of the polygons that is not
consistent with the comprehension
hypothesis my work I'm in big trouble so
this is a stringent test right trick
with case histories is to look at a lot
of them
so I went through the ones I knew I
spent a lot of time on alone cuttle I
knew when I met in Hungary and Steve
Kaufman whom you may have heard of and
went through what they said at each
stage from both of their books their
reactions and they were amazingly
parallel what is clear is that both
neither rejected grammar neither rejects
grammar after use rejects and rejected
right low cantos passed away both have
an interest in it both let alone cazzo
told me I just love grammar it's so
interesting it's nice that you're here
and I can talk to you
you can't discuss these things with your
neighbors but she said it's really
overdone she recommends for adult
students just do it should be optional
and just the regular form of verbs don't
do anything else and with children the
idea of teaching grammar is
absurd just you know I'll just jump in
here but I think this is a very
important point and that is that that by
stressing input as you do compelling
input even though there are people who
are attracted to learning grammar for
different reasons and stuff like that
I still think and I do occasionally look
at it and forget it and stuff it's so
important to to make the point that the
input is where the learning takes place
that's not to say don't learn grammar
right and I want to introduce throw back
to you the idea that two of the
polyglots here very accomplished
polyglots richard Simchat and luca a
poor yellow they do other things like
richard Simchat likes attending language
class and i interviewed Richard and Luka
has a technique where he translates from
the language he's learning into his own
language and then back into the language
however if you really analyze where they
spend most of their time what do you
think it is comprehensible input
everybody does it some people do this
some people do that they do a wide
variety they all do comprehensible in
turn it's the only universal feature I
have found in successful language
writers now to bridge to my other new
thinking what people do is they have
strategies for making input
comprehensible good teachers do this and
the polyglot students teachers they
might be telling a story
they'll come to a word that they're
pretty sure the class doesn't know
they'll explain it they might translate
it they might give a synonym they might
draw a picture it's not designed for you
to learn the word and remember it right
it's designed to make the text more
comprehensible absolutely the irony is
if you do that enough it'll help you
acquire the word you know I can't resist
jumping in we call the meaning of the
word at link when you look it up we call
it a hint exactly we do not call it the
meaning really it is a hint and we know
from experience that if you and of
course the word changes from blue to
yellow and if you see that yellow
reminder that you've actually seen the
word before and if you see it often
enough eventually the pick
that totals only the word at a time it
comes exactly
so before we went on the air I told
Steve then I figured out a way where I
can use his system to my own advantage
I've been doing Mandarin great fun
you've got to be like you I just it's so
interesting to be struggling all the
time
I do it not only for the pleasure but as
part of my research yes it has to fit
Sun constantly examining it and I have
decided for a while to not worry about
characters I did characters for a while
and this correlates with Steve Kaufman's
experience was the way he did Mandarin
but to do a lot of opinion and a lot of
listening mm-hmm but I've decided when I
go to on see when I go to the characters
again it's gonna be with your system
right it's gonna be absolutely perfect I
can get it a little at a time let it
build up this of course is the park with
link it's it's based on reading and
listening exactly this you have to have
the characters however my experience
with learning Kent a Mandarin was the
first month I had intensive exposure to
these dialogues with audio and pinyin so
that when I went to learn the characters
I had a reference a word that I knew the
sound of knew the meaning of and I think
whenever we learned something if we can
tie it to something that we already know
we're gonna learn it better this is so
interesting because this is exactly what
happened to me a month ago I decided to
start listening and reading at the same
time the opinion right and it's so much
fun
oh yeah the weird thing is happening
with one I did a couple of books with
Linda Lee my first Mandarin teacher
that's so wonderful and we have it in
pinyin and characters and it's recorded
so I've been listening to the stories
which I helped write all right you know
I think they're interesting and I've
been listening to her reading them very
slowly and carefully and I've been yeah
I've gone through it about you know each
chapter about ten times now fifteen
times it's interesting it's nice she
does a nice job
the other day I picked it up and read it
alone
I heard her voice in my head yes
reading the story yeah the correct
pronunciation is beginning to be
acquired right absorbed the tones
sounded right and at some point and at
some point you will have enough of the
language in you that you want to output
it yeah it's coming that's right
but there's our oh my great experience
of the Mandarin I've had a few nice
conversations right I was in düsseldorf
in the airport transitioning from one
plane to the other coming home from
Czech Republic another story and was
traveling with Jason Fritz who's this
phenomenal TRS teacher enroll there's a
big Jam up in the airport there are all
these people and they don't know what to
do
the people next to us in line were all
from China they did not speak German
they did not speak English there I was I
spoke Mandarin to them they went
absolutely crazy I would say things like
oh you know May when tea and they said
oh that's so nice because oh that's
wonderful so we had this broken
conversation at the end I went ahead of
them to do the passport check and they
were behind me and I said you know okay
goodbye
well I mean you know and they just have
plotted they were very upset in the
beginning and at the end they felt a lot
better yeah mom cat though has said
language is something where if you only
know a little it's a good thing right if
you only know a little of science it can
be dangerous as Donald Trump Illustrated
to us but if you only know if you only
know a little of the language it's a
virtue right enjoy it and while I'm
talking to Steve Kaufman I might as well
tell people this reading his book and
listening to his interview at this
conference has been a great therapeutic
help Steve has made a couple of points
that really hit home with me and will
with others first of all he says other
people generally don't care if you make
mistakes
they are not judging you right and
people like us who are so excited about
grammar we think if it's not perfect we
shouldn't say it etc so that has taken a
lot of pressure off and also the other
day the Mandarin is coming slowly Steve
has said you know you always think
you're gonna be real fast and it's never
quite as fast as you think but once
you're sucked in you can't stop which is
exactly what has happened and he has
said what I'd love passing this on when
that happens just keep reading and
listening don't worry about it
just keep reading and listening and that
seems to be the cure Hey exactly and I
and I say often that I think experience
language learners as I'm struggling in
Hebrew right now yeah I'm struggling I
mean every day I go to read it and again
I can't remember like the letters and
what they mean and I hope you're
listening to this Steve Kaufman saying
this in at two weeks now and I know from
experience I know from my experience
with other languages that it will
eventually come and so it doesn't bother
me but I think it discourages a lot of
people because they put so much effort
in and they constantly forget yes you
forget and you don't realize I don't
really rely on memory there was a
presentation here about different ways
of remembering I don't rely on it at all
and and one thing I wanted to mention
which I haven't mentioned to you but I
was doing some reading on the brain and
stuff how it works and by forcing
yourself to learn Chinese you're forcing
the brain to do something that's new
that you haven't done before and that is
creating new neural connections it is Oh
expanding it's it's it's it's taking
advantage of that plasticity which if at
our age we basically are no longer
interested in doing new things then
actually we start losing some of those
neural connections so the process of
reading the process of listening is
expanding our brain we will eventually
get to our goal the process by which we
learn I think is more tied to the
listening and reading than it is to any
deliberate instruction deliberate you
know study of some aspect of the
language so you're on the right path you
just have to stay the course and I will
on Hebrew and you will
Chinese anthem walk do this a couple of
things got at the same time with both
you and me we're not only trying to get
comprehensible input and acquire the
language but we're examining the process
as we do it and we're problem-solving
we're working at the same time we're
doing this we're both all of us all the
polyglots are working on theory we're
constructing a theory of language
acquisition by constantly refining it
changing it and learning new things
right we're going through cognitive
development at the same time the
parallel Theory the comprehensible input
was learning in general is we get
smarter by trying to solve problems
right linus pauling knew more about
chemistry than anyone who ever lived
he spent 60 years trying to solve every
problem of significance in the field of
chemistry and many and physics
encyclopedic knowledge doesn't come from
studying it comes from problem solving
right and in terms of problem solving
each of us wants to solve different
problems we all have our own path the
Casso says find your gift develop it and
give it away
I find your path Mark Twain says the two
most important days of your life the day
you're born the day you discover why
what your path is when you find your
path you solve problems in that path
you're happy you're in love with your
work and you get smarter the only way to
get smart genius means you've discovered
your path geniuses are people who
discovered their path right and stick to
it that's why we're so happy and
absolutely and if you're doing something
that matters to you it's gotta be
yourself solving problems that matter to
you you're you do it you mentioned flow
flow theory you tell me highly so it'll
be a brilliant book flow check it out
that's wonderful so basically that's
what we have income yes well in his book
player piano yeah I player piano cat's
cradle Veronica says we are all divided
into teams caress and members of your
team you were working on the same task
to solve the same problem
and that your teammate could be anyone
could be somebody working at the
drugstore somewhere someone you met in a
bar it could be your cousin maybe some
of you know about you go to get these
polyglots together we're members of the
same team and our job is to work
together to solve these problems
absolutely which makes us happy
non-competitive I've the same goal
before we went on the air we were just
talking about the polyglots here
wonderful interesting relaxed sorority
there's learning yeah whatever so we
should perhaps end on on the following
note and that is that you don't have to
be a renowned language acquisition
acquisition expert like stephen krashen
or youtube producer you know you don't
have to know five languages ten or
fifteen if you are at all interested in
languages please make a point of
attending the next polyglot gathering or
lung fest
or similar function near you you won't
regret it this is my first it's amazing
having a good time okay thank you bye
[Music]